[Music]
now I'm not a big social gamer on the
whole but I am a big fan of a game that
lets you get stuck into a campaign
cooperatively my love of co-op campaign
started when my dad my brother and I
would log onto our respective computers
in three different rooms of our house
our version of a LAN was to get on
Diablo and shout between rooms at each
other for stealing one another's loot
and getting the escort mission dude
killed since Diablo loads of publishers
have realized the value of selling it
not just a multiplayer experience but an
entirely cooperative games while MMOs of
obviously fully embraced multiplayer and
games like torchlight Borderlands and
Taylor has set wonderful foundations
here are five of my favorite games that
offer cooperative campaign when Diablo x
came to an inevitable close sacred was
there to pick up the slack the third
installment is out this week and
although it's been getting pretty mixed
reviews the first two installments were
great having been released in 2004 and
2008 respectively sacred and sacred
Teufel and Angel carried me through the
day-to-day grind of high school when
modern history class wasn't offering up
all the excitement I'd expected
liberating the vast world of ancaria
from the mysterious substance of t
energy as a kick-ass seraphim was
seriously enticing sacred is an awesome
hack and slash RPG complete with melts
metric tons of quests and RPG elements
like stat allocation and skill choice
both of which have seriously scaled down
in many modern RPGs sacred 3 included
next up is the first major [ __ ] console
game I ever got stuck into army off - I
messed around in Call of Duty before but
shooters we're never really in my bag
although that didn't get in the way of
me happily embodying the life sarcastic
pretty boy gunner in army of two while
my brother adopted the role of his buddy
a standard brute the main thing I
remember about that game was pimping out
all my guns with epic bling and nice
understated gold plating then there was
the fact that the entire campaign was
designed for you to play with a friend
which wasn't something I'd seen much of
before army of chair designed Corp in an
engaging way and was probably the first
shooter to make me realize how enormous
Lee fun upgrading your weapons and
mowing down baddies without really
caring about who they were or why you
were shooting at them could be I'd be
seriously remiss not to talk about the
game specifically designed to be played
by multiple people so let's talk about
what's so great about left 4 dead 2 not
only does it cleverly include two
numbers in the name the fact that the
survival horror shooter has been built
around your group means cop isn't just
encouraged it's vital you're one of the
few survivors of the zombie apocalypse
facing off against the Boomers and which
is to make your way through five
campaigns said campaigns alluded with
baddies safe houses and levels with
dynamic elements generated through the
game's AI director there are a variety
of both ranged and melee weapons to
choose from and it's a matter of playing
to your strengths as well as working
together with your team to survive the
game can get tricky especially if you
opted for realism mode which removes
respawns among other helpful gamey
features but if you've got three friends
handy there are certainly worse ways to
spend an evening
this one isn't your typical cop campaign
but it is still valve so since we're on
the topic let's talk portal to two
friends or two randoms on the internet
embody the testing robots atlas and
p-body each has a portal gun of their
own but both must work together to
complete a lengthy series of test
chambers after which they're brutally
ripped apart only to be reassembled
ready to go at the next chamber
this form of co-op is particularly
clever in how it demands that the
players work together sure the robot
buddies can high-five and chat til the
cows come home but without some proper
communication those test chambers will
stay unsolved it's probably worth noting
that while portal to co-op chambers can
be an awful lot of fun there's a fine
line between this game making or
breaking your friendships if you'd like
a little more narrative bang you're
caught buck then you'd be hard-pressed
to go past dead space 3 the
psychological minefield that is dead
space three's campaign is only fully
unveiled once you get into it with a
friend
one of you embodies series staple Isaac
Clark while the other takes on the role
of newcomer
Sergeant John cava the drop-in dropout
co-op mode includes different
experiences for each character where
Carver will find toy soldiers in a
biological facility Clark isn't able to
see them the characters are also
interestingly independent of one another
at some point there's a situation where
Carver finds himself thrown into a
paralyzing psychosis forcing Clark to
protect him from a search of Necromorphs
this throws a new facet into the classic
co-op campaign formula and it sure is
comforting to have a buddy around when
the Necromorph limbs hit the fan let me
know down in that trusty comment section
which game has your favorite co-op
campaign and this week I'll leave you
with some of the awesome hallucination
scenes from dead space 3
what is it when you finish here
[Music]
you okay no not again
Dylan hey if you're seeing something
that isn't there you to tell me okay
Carver jelly Carver Gillian